first of all you guys all won a tony
award for best revival of a play
did you know at that time that this was
going to turn into a movie
jim we'll start with you we did know
and oh only after we won
did i realize how shitty it would have
been to not
win and then go right into production it
made a nice difference to go in
as tony winners
i love that um brian what would it mean
for you you know it's it was a tony but
what if it
if it went to a golden globe or an oscar
like i'm
daydreaming over here for all of you um
what would that mean
well i mean it would be amazing
certainly i think
none of us were thinking of those things
as we were filming it it was a challenge
um in its own right and to to you know
adapt this from the stage to the screen
and uh
it was just such a pleasant experience
and so great to work with all these guys
again so
you know anything that would happen
after that it would be amazing and then
you know i hope that people really love
the film i think it's beautiful so
it would be cool yeah brian okay michael
you want that golden globe oscar come on
now i know you do i can see it in your
eyes
you know this whole process has been a
celebration of mark crowley's play
and his work in his life and his legacy
uh he passed away in march
which we mourn but we're so happy that
his story
and the legacy of the story continues
forward you know it's always been about
getting mart
his broadway debut at 84 years old so if
an oscar came
i still think what an incredible
celebration of
of mark's bravery 52 years ago i love
that
um this story this play i mean it has
such a rich history
in the lgbtq plus community but for all
of us
it's very meaningful um jim for you
you know what does this play in this
film mean to you
well i mean it means a lot of things to
me at different levels but
in a very general sense what it might
mean to everybody
i see is just how
harmful it is to be taught in any way or
learn from your society
that that what you are isn't good enough
or is actually even bad
and the ways in which being told that by
society makes people
can make people act out in very hateful
hurtful
ways i think so much of the turmoil in
this
story the things that go on during this
evening this party
that are so hurtful come from a place
of um feeling beaten down by the world
that these men are living in
um my character seems to be handling it
a little worse than the rest but at the
same time
they're just to varying degrees they're
all in similar shoes
as it were and um yeah it's important to
to love one another and for equality i
love that
thank you um with social distancing in
2020
are y'all on zoom a lot like birthdays
group chats like what kind of
connections are y'all making with each
other right now
i earn a book club that goes on zoom
book club jim and i started we were in a
book club about 15 years ago and we
restarted it during the pandemic which
has been one of the highlights honestly
because
it's a great way socially to get
together with people that we've known
for a long time and so uh
yeah i see his face probably more than
anybody else's
and we have a good text chain we have a
good text chain of the group of the of
the boys
so yeah yeah i feel like it might be i
feel like the group chat might be a
little dangerous
yeah yes okay well thank you guys for
your time it was such a pleasure
speaking to you all